[Música]
Naciones Unidas condena a Perú por
vulnerar los derechos de Camila una niña
peruana a la que se le forzó a mantener
un embarazo resultado de una violación
sexual y a quien luego se le señaló como
una criminal por tener un aborto
espontáneo este caso se suma a las
luchas por los derechos reproductivos de
las niñas y de las mujeres y lo abanderó
la organización niñas no madres que hizo
la denuncia vamos a conversar
precisamente con mariani Sánchez ella es
directora de comunicaciones para América
Latina de plant global y también vocera
del movimiento son niñas no madres
mariani Gracias por estar en directo
América
Hola qué tal Ángela muy buenos días y
muchas gracias por esta invitación para
abordar un poco más las implicaciones de
ese dictamen de la ONU en el caso de
Camila versus Perú muy buenos días bien
son niñas no madres interpuso la demanda
ante el organismo en 2020 y evidenció
que Camila sufrió un aborto espontáneo y
que se le vulneraron sus derechos
humanos para empezar le quiero pedir por
favor un breve resumen del caso para que
nuestros televidentes puedan hacerse a
una idea de su magnitud
Claro que sí Ángela Bueno realmente el
caso se presentó en 2020 por dos
organizaciones una plan paran en Hot
global que es la Organización que
represento y la otra una organización
local del Perú que es prompsex el caso
de Camila es elocuente de la dolorosa
realidad que tienen que atravesar las
niñas que son por un lado víctima de
violencia sexual y al mismo tiempo son
forzadas a ser madres Camila quedó
embarazada luego de cuatro años de
abusos reiterados por parte de su propio
padre los abusos empezaron en los nueve
años Camila quedó embarazada a los Trece
años ella no sabía que estaba embarazada
también porque las condiciones de vida
de Camila que vivían una zona rural con
mucha precariedad tampoco le permitieron
tener acceso a educación sexual integral
que le permitieran reconocer que los
síntomas
síntomas de embarazo pero cuando
finalmente se da cuenta por la
sintomatología ella manifiesta en
reiteradas oportunidades que quiere
acceder a un aborto terapéutico que es
un aborto que es legal en el Perú desde
1924 cuando la salud y la vida de la
mujer o personas gestante o niña está en
riesgo evidentemente el embarazo de
Camila era un embarazo que no era
compatible con su bienestar está
documentado que los embarazos infantiles
generan cuatro veces mayor probabilidad
de que esas niñas tengan complicaciones
graves durante el embarazo durante el
parto incluso durante el postparto y a
pesar de que en Perú existe esta
normativa y de que ella y su mamá
manifestaron en varias oportunidades que
querían acceder a ese aborto terapéutico
nunca se le dio una respuesta
básicamente se le negó por omisión se
dilató tanto la respuesta en el centro
de salud que no se dio eventualmente
semanas después ella tiene un aborto
espontáneo y con todo y que tiene un
aborto espontáneo la fiscal que estaba
llevando su caso y que estaba procesando
a su padre por el delito de violación
sexual la acusó de autoborto y la
sometió a diferentes investigaciones en
su casa la policía la visitó reiteradas
veces en su casa lo que además ocasionó
que su comunidad que el núcleo que podía
haberla apoyado las personas de su
escuela en lugar de apoyarla la
señalaran entonces Camila vivió No
solamente la violencia en su propio
cuerpo y la violencia sexual se le
obligó a mantener ese embarazo producto
de la violencia sexual Pero además su
salud mental y su salud social se vio
totalmente resquebrajada por las
diferentes revictimizaciones de las
cuales fue objeto Camila pues muchas
gracias por esa introducción y
entendiendo eso esta decisión del comité
marca un paso que es significativo hacia
la protección de los derechos de las
niñas peruanas y hace una serie de
llamados al Estado del Perú por ejemplo
a despenalizar el aborto en todos los
supuestos de embarazo infantil y le
quiero preguntar Pues en qué está el
país en términos de derechos sexuales y
reproductivos porque es necesario hacer
esta aclaración de acabar con las
prohibiciones a finalización de
embarazos infantiles en el país porque
al final pues una niña que sufre un
embarazo pues es una niña que fue
violada
de acuerdo exactamente y de hecho el
fondo de población de Naciones Unidas
también ha dicho que en el Perú
diariamente cuatro niñas entre 10 y 14
años se convierten en madres Esta no es
una realidad única del Perú Esta es una
epidemia silenciosa que es común a toda
América Latina y el Caribe y por eso es
que es tan importante esta clase de
dictamen que además emana de un órgano
como Naciones Unidas para que se pueda
ampliar el acceso a la interrupción
voluntaria del embarazo en estos casos y
que además se incluya de manera
intencional el caso de los embarazos
infantiles que como tú bien dijiste
cuando estamos hablando de un embarazo
infantil estamos hablando de un embarazo
que es producto de violación en Perú es
particularmente importante esta Victoria
por qué Por lo que acabo de decir a
pesar de que el aborto terapéutico en
Perú Es legal desde 1924 en las causales
salud y vida Aunque no digamos el
protocolizó su acceso sino hasta 2014 no
se había contemplado todavía la causal
violación ni se había considerado el
embarazo infantil eso también habla de
una omisión tremenda de los riesgos y de
los daños en la salud tanto física como
social como mental que ocasiona el
embarazo infantil
Pues en las niñas entonces Emma hay otro
tema porque ya nos vamos quedando sin
tiempo y es que si Camila no hubiera
sufrido un aborto se habría convertido
en una niña madre otra más de miles de
que hay en nuestra región sin embargo
esto es una práctica absolutamente común
y normalizada lo que uno tendría que ver
es que se realicen denuncias cada vez
que uno ve una niña en un estado de
matrimonio forzado o de una maternidad
forzada Pero esto no pasa porque está
tan normalizado
a ver yo creo que para hablar de la
normalización y también de la magnitud y
de la persistencia de las de las
maternidades forzadas en Perú y en
América Latina hay que ir a la causa de
esas maternidades forzadas que es la
violencia sexual y en nuestra región
tenemos una combinación tóxica de tres
elementos Uno de ellos es la impunidad
que tú acabas de decir no Y la ausencia
de una cultura de denuncia hay esa
combinación tóxica que permite que esté
este caldo de cultivo para que esta
realidad no cambie Entonces por un lado
está la impunidad y la ausencia de una
cultura de denuncia que está vinculada
directamente a una normalización que
existe en las comunidades e incluso en
las familias de que se violentan a las
mujeres a las mujeres y a las niñas y
además que se entienda que los cuerpos
de las mujeres y las niñas se pueden
consumir y violentar y además de eso de
esta combinación entre impunidad y
naturalización de la violencia tenemos
que ir también al corazón de esta
naturalización de la violencia como toda
otra violencia por razón de género
una cultura machista que le resta valía
a las mujeres y a las niñas y también
autonomía para poder una vez
enfrentándose un acto un hecho
victimizante como esto poder decidir
Cómo retomar su proyecto de vida e
incluso decidir por ejemplo interrumpir
voluntariamente un embarazo que es
producto de la violencia sexual eso se
une también a una romantización de la
idea de la maternidad a un punto tal de
que casi que se justifica que por
cualquier medio así sea viviendo El
infierno de la violación sexual se llega
a la maternidad y se debe asumir esta
maternidad porque hay una relación
directa efectiva entre mujer niña como
mujer en potencia y madre pues mariani
nos quedamos sin tiempo Yo le agradezco
mucho por poner este caso sobre la mesa
de France 24 ella es directora de
comunicaciones para América Latina de
plan de Hood global y vocera del
movimiento son niños no madres para
finalizar mariani pues tomo prestado el
nombre de su movimiento porque lo que
queremos es tener niñas y no mamás
Muchas gracias a usted a nuestros
televidentes sigan con nosotros en
directo América y ya volvemos con más